دعيني ابدا معك اولا بالموقف الامريكي
بشان قرار اوبك بلس كيف تقيمين تعامل
اداره بايرن مع هذا القرار
المتعلقه بالطاقه تم تحديدها من قبر ياسر
ولا علاقه لها بالسياسه العقلانيه او
بحقيقه السوق والوقائع فقد اصبحت الولايات
المتحده اثناء حكم الرئيس ترامب دوله
مصدره للطاقه لكن عندما حال الجو بيض
بالبيت الابيض كان اول قراراته غلق
انبوكستون كما وقع قرارات تنفيذيه دمرت
عمليا صناعه الطاقه الامريكيه لذلك عندما
واجه بدايه الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وعندما وصله لاحقا قرار كلاس بقدر الانتاج
وجاد بايظ نفسه في وضع اليائس لكن للاسف
هو من صنع ذلك الوضع ويتحمل مسؤوليته
والحقيقه انه فقد الواقعيه والمنطق في
التعامل مع هذا الملف وهو ما زال مصر على
المضيء في نفس سيادته ولا يرغب في تعديلها
واسماء اقيامه بذلك نجح في ابعاد احد اكبر
خلفاء الولايات المتحده التق
والاستراتيجيين لمده اكثر من 70 عاما
المملكه العربيه السعوديه واعتقد ان الشعب
الامريكي سيعاقب حزب بعض في مراكز
الاقتراع وسنعرف الاثار في الاسابيع
المقبله